hello everyone I am in amazing
Washington DC here at the food and
nutrition conference and Expo I'm really
excited to see what is going on and what
all amazing food products they've got in
the store okay so we're taking a little
interlude from a conference to pop of
course and I'm in the mother's room
which is this amazing innovative idea I
mean I don't know why all conferences
don't have this but basically it allows
moms to come and breastfeed their babies
or pump in private and everyone gets a
nice little pod they can store your pump
you can store your milk here it is
absolutely ingenious
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys so we've got old our snacks
in tow and honestly this package almost
did not make it up here to Canada
because the customs officer did not like
how I filled out my forms but we got it
I was determined to bring you this home
so I could share some my favorite snacks
in the conference so let's dive in and
we're gonna start with these guys
popped chickpea toes super cute name
really delicious basically these are
baked green peas and chickpeas and kind
of like a fun almost like a cheesy kind
of snack but they're great so they've
got 130 calories per ounce with 3 grams
of fiber and 4 grams of protein and
these are the zesty brand bustin a good
time steak because I sample these acids
pod the conference and they were so
tasty really easy to eat light crunchy
what's not to love love that
branching alright we're gonna stick the
same chickpea theme here these are fun
these are chickpea crumbs and I love
this idea they're organic they're gluten
free so if you're looking for a gluten
free alternative to breading or like
panko breadcrumbs if you're making
chicken fingers or fish fingers this is
awesome basically in 1/8 of a cup you've
got 4 grams of fiber and 5 grams of
protein so even if you're not included
free you're gonna get some out of
nutrition in this and I really love that
so I'm definitely looking forward to
using this this weekend all right
Oh fun messy monkey nutsy monkey I love
this this is so cute and it's the
branding is so fun for kids which I'm
now thinking about as a mom I mean I'm
always thinking about snacks so these
are apple cinnamon flavor for a sweet
and we've got a cheese flavor these are
cute little messy monkey snacks but
they're made with sorghum and quinoa so
really really great stuff each little
cute bag Ethier has 2 grams of protein
and a gram of fiber and 60 calories so
kind of a fun little snack for the
kiddos and for parents too so you can
see what they look like they're like
little OHS but hmm French feet not very
sweet I'm a big fan all right pasta
pasta I'm always in the mood for pasta
and if we can make pasta even healthier
I am all for it
so this is modern table rotini it's a
complete protein gluten free pasta and I
find a lot of gluten-free pastas are
kind of you know flavorless or the
textures a little bit off but I sample
this at the conference
definitely a big fan so it's made with
just red lentil flour white rice and pea
protein so in one serving two answers of
dry pasta we've got 11 grams of protein
and 3 grams of fiber so even if you're
not gluten free this is a great way to
add some extra protein to your pasta
dinner so big fan of it all right okay
now let's go into breakfast skipping
from dinner to prog fit breakfast
because that's how we roll so this is
fun this is thick thins protein and
probiotics pot oatmeal this is
definitely a theme a trend that I saw at
the conference quite a bit which was
that everyone's loving the oats these
days and I definitely agree because it's
cold outside and I'm always looking for
an easy way to get my oats in but this
is great because you just add the water
and I sample this it was really tasty
one bowl has 200 calories it's got 10
grams of protein and 6 grams of fiber
plus it's got probiotics and that's
another big big trend this year is
probiotics in everything so these are
really tasty this one's cinnamon almond
and this one's maple pecan so for those
those mornings where you can't get
yourself together this is going to be an
amazing breakfast all right
so these are super fun I love these I
was super impressed with these these are
vegetarian travelers toasted bean blends
so there's a few different options this
one is a try soy medley this one is
Pepita soy pee medley and garbanzo and
soy medley
so unlike traditionally we think about
like you always have to cook your
chickpeas maybe you put them in hummus
or you make up soup these are like
little toppers to add crunch to your
soup or your salad or even yogurt this
is another really great idea so you
wanna do like a savory yogurt which i
think is also definitely on trend this
year but they're great because for
example this one one package you could
just tote this around with you just kind
of add some more protein to your meal
one pack is 170 calories
we've got 15 grams of protein and 3
grams of fiber that's pretty impressive
right there for really not a lot of
calories so I love that on top of yogurt
you have a really stay trading snack all
right awesome what else we got whoa who
knew SHhhh
I loved this product all their stuff was
really fun but this is their 100% almond
protein powder so I mean for those who
you don't digest way very well if you're
looking for another alternative when it
comes to protein powders this almond
protein powder was actually really tasty
and one pack has 120 calories with 21
grams of protein and 5 grams of fiber so
I find most protein powders don't really
have any fiber in there but this is
gonna add that extra fiber
so you can just add this with your
smoothies or mix it with water really
really tasty really really tasty alright
next next next
alright speaking of nuts cuz I love me
some nuts these are so fun this is our
ex nut butters I'm a big fan of the rx
bars but these are really cool because
inside they have one egg white 27
peanuts in this case I think there might
be almonds here as this also this is
also peanuts a half a date to sweeten
and no BS as they say so this is the
honey cinnamon peanut butter I have the
vanilla almond butter which was
absolutely amazing
and then the classic peanut butter great
for just bringing around if you need
some extra protein in your day so one
little pouch here has 190 calories with
9 grams of protein and 2 grams of fiber
so a really great way to add something
really to satiating to your meals throw
it on some crackers put it on a bagel
put it in your oats or your yogurt
amazing alright
so we're sticking with the nut butter
kind of theme and we've got this awesome
unreal candy so this is dark chocolate
peanut butter and this is the dark
chocolate peanut butter crispy they are
like little peanut butter cups that are
absolutely addictive I ate so many of
them at the conference but the reason
why I really like this brand is they
have they don't use any kind of
artificial flavors or colors which I
thought was really important especially
if you are giving a Halloween candy and
you want to avoid some of that those
dies in a lot of food mmm
all the crispy so Shogun mmm but these
are also gluten-free if it's got five
grams of sugar in them vegan non-gmo
unreal taste I totally totally agree so
yummy all right second one more to go
babe all right these are fun
these are flapjack mighty muffins so I
also sample this and I was like a really
big fan again the probiotics and them
because the probiotics and everything
now and basically you add water and you
microwave this and you get 20 grams of
protein in this little kind of muffin
cup it's a personalized size muffin made
to order which sounds amazing
regardless but then add in the fact you
get protein and probiotics and I'm
pretty impressed
so 220 calories 5 grams of fiber and 20
grams of protein yes yes police so this
one is banana caramel hello
chocolate peanut butter equally delish I
cannot wait to dive in yes so fancy this
year was definitely a huge hit I clearly
got a lot of snacks and really excited
to eat all of them
but if you guys enjoyed this video be
sure to give me the thumbs up leave me a
comment below with some of the cool
innovative new snacks that you have seen
on store shelves subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen
[Music]